and to another Legendary Collection you
know the saying more than an athlete
well Jim irsay owner of the NFL's
Indianapolis Colts is more than an owner
and CEO he's a collector and a curator
he chatted with Rocky about the Jim
irsay collection exhibit and concert
he's bringing it to Las Vegas this
weekend featuring his iconic artifacts
and band and you are invited
can you just go back to explaining what
the collection is
um you know how you got these pieces and
and where it started I collected
baseball cards as a kid and and then
like you know the kids would get mad
because I pedaled on my bike to the
drugstore and I'd buy the whole box you
know save up save up money uh because I
used to deal hot dog gunman school I buy
for five cents and sell for 25. already
a capitalist honest on his run but uh
that's why you're here now right I know
I somehow I was gonna lead to something
I guess I A friend of mine gave me Elvis
Presley's guitar because they had
museums in North America and Canada and
so I had you know Elvis's guitar and
kind of that was like it and then and
then all of a sudden you know um the
scroll came available in New York City
you know through Christie's Jack airwax
on the road Scroll once I had that then
like I was a collector and then it
happened quick Jerry Garcia's tiger his
famous uh guitar made by Doug Irwin and
Bob Dylan's Newport Folk Festival and
then it just went on John Lennon's piano
that was in his house which is one of
the most that he wrote Sergeant Pepper's
on uh Elton John's Piano from live aided
Freddie Mercury and Paul McCartney
played that John Lennon's last
performance in 74 with Elton John the
Madison Square Garden played
um that's Elton played at the great
shows at Dodger Stadium in 74 Benny and
the Jets so it just built but it you
know it's very eclectic it hasn't been
put together randomly you know it's been
put together real specifically and you
look for things that jumped decades and
transcend Generations at this point in
my life I'm about service like we don't
charge any money for the shows in fact
in Indy we bought people drinks and hot
dogs because it's like you've given so
much to sports entertainment with your
dollar you've given so much to rock and
roll to the Eagles to Bruce Springsteen
to you know to Stevie Wonder to Michael
Jackson whatever just you know this is
free you know this is saying thank you
for supporting the Arts I'm a curator
and and kind of just I I try to be just
a steward of these things and make sure
people see them because a lot of times
people will buy them and sock them away
you know and where did it go no one
knows you know so
um it's it's been so fun that way Rocky
you know just
um being able to see the people being
able to enjoy it and really until you
come to a show like you think you know
what you're gonna see but people walk
away and they'll tell you they'll go oh
my God I I didn't think like I was gonna
see this kind of Museum pieces and then
see a full show for two hours now I have
to ask you one last question yes a
little football related yes how do we
feel about the Super Bowl coming to
Vegas about the growth of oh man that's
a great you know that's a great question
you know being in the league 52 years I
never thought
I would see this beautiful stadium in in
Vegas and playing in Vegas it was always
taboo Vegas has become very
family-centric now all the you know
resident shows that are there you know
um and just the way they've made you
know I've known a lot of um my dad
actually knew Howard Hughes way way back
in the day and you know Stephen Howard
music houses here on our is on our
station lot no way yeah you gotta come
by we're so excited about you know just
um the Super Bowl being there is going
to be epic you know and and I know how
excited people are going to be it's
going to be crazy you know
um you guys one thing for sure you have
the hotels to handle the Super Bowl say
that
all right thanks to the Jim irsay
collection for sponsoring this segment
the event's free it's open to the public
this Saturday from 6 00 P.M to 11 p.m at
the downtown Las Vegas event center if
you want tickets and more information
just head to Jim irsay collection.com